[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hey friends Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I want to teach
you how to do a reverse three beat weave
with your POI but before we dive in I
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel Becca beckonen thank you so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission so recently I have had several
students that have been playing around
with learning how to do a reverse three
beat weave and it did dawn on me that
there are some techniques around this
that are notably different enough from
learning the forwards three beat weave
that it might be worth doing a tutorial
just on this trick alone so in this
tutorial I'm going to give you as
comprehensive an approach to learning
this trick as I possibly can that
process is going to take several steps
and you may not get all of them in one
day but I guarantee you that if you do
work through each of these steps the
trick is waiting for you on the other
side cool so if your game Let's jump in
step one learning to do a reverse Tic
Tac
all right so first things first when
we're performing a reverse three beat
weave fundamentally what we're doing is
we're passing the POI back and forth
across our body in what we would
normally refer to as a Tic Tac or a two
beat this is also sometimes called a
reel depending upon what part of your
body it's around but the terminology you
don't need to worry about that much what
we are doing here is essentially
spinning the POI in a reverse direction
that is it is going backwards past our
shoulders and forwards past our ankles
and we're moving the POI from side to
side of our body now this is really
important both when it is on its native
side that is if I'm using my right hand
when it's on my right side as well as
when it's on the non-native side that is
when my right hand is on my left side
you should still see the same pattern
the top of the POI is going back away
from you and the bottom of it is going
forwards away from you that'll be both
on the right side as well as on the left
side to get back and forth we need to
use something called a Cross Point I've
already done a video that explains a
cross point in depth that I'll go ahead
and link to down in the description as
well as up in the cards but the long
short of it is this you're basically
bending the Poise path back and forth
across your body in order to move it
from side to side to learn how to do
this I would actually just start by
using your arm so wrap your POI up in
your head and perform this series of
motions with me you're going to start
with your right hand next to your right
hip and you're going to reach it
straight out away from you you're next
going to reach it directly up above your
left shoulder and then reach it back
past your left shoulder so you've
basically got your arm across your whole
body at this point next you're going to
reach it down towards your left hip and
then straight out away from you again
next you're going to reach straight up
above your right shoulder and back past
your right shoulder and finally down
next to your right hip and we start the
whole pattern over again let me show you
that from the other angle so starting at
the right hip we reach straight out away
from us we reach directly above the left
shoulder we reach behind the left
shoulder down next to the left hip out
and away
above the right shoulder behind the
right shoulder and down next to the
right hip
away above the left shoulder behind the
left shoulder next to the left hip away
above the right shoulder behind the
right shoulder next to the right hip you
want to practice going through each and
every one of these positions to make it
feel comfortable once it does feel
comfortable you want to try and move
straight between each of these points in
a smooth continuous motion or as smooth
as you can once you get to be confident
with this you can go ahead and let one
coil out of the POI and essentially
treat the POI as though it is an
extension of your hand as you take it
back and forth you want the POI to be
sticking out away from you the entire
time and when it gets to feel
comfortable with the POI going out a
single coil you're going to let the full
POI out and again let the POI act as an
extension of your arm as you move it
back and forth across your body in this
fashion so once you're in a position
where you're pretty comfortable having
the POI acting as an extension of your
arm you want to go ahead and reduce the
size of those circles that your arm is
creating and until you're just producing
these circles back and forth with the
POI itself essentially the POI has now
become your arm you just use the arm
kind of like training wheels and going
through this and once you're in this
position hey check it out that's that
reverse Tic Tac nicely done
foreign
[Music]
and of course once you get this down
with the right hand you want to learn
the same thing with your left hand the
series of positions is going to be as
such you start at the left hip Reach Out
forward in front of you reach above the
right shoulder back behind the right
shoulder down next to the right hip
straight out away from you directly
above your left shoulder back behind
your left shoulder and down next to your
left hip again reaching straight out
away above the right shoulder back
behind the right shoulder next to the
right hip out and Away above the left
shoulder behind left shoulder and down
next to the left hip aside from that
though the process is exactly the same
you move your hand back and forth
through all these different parts you
let out a single coil the POI you let
out the POI to full length and then you
work your way down to just having the
POI performing this motion back and
forth just like that awesome now you're
ready for step two step two spending the
POI in Reverse split Time same direction
so most of us have a natural inclination
to spin our POI in together same that is
we have the POI moving together as they
go around on the sides of us now the
thing is to do a reverse three beat
weave we have to learn how to have our
POI spin in Split Time same direction
instead if those words seem like Greek
to you I did do a video explaining
timing and direction for POI that I'll
go ahead and link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you're watching on YouTube but the
Cliff's Notes are as such rather than
thinking of the POI as both either
coming at you or going away from you at
the same time you want to kind of
imagine that you're performing a drum
beat with them thinking one two one two
one two one two and there's a lot of
ways that you could learn how to do this
but one of my favorites is actually to
kind of come at it from the side and
that is to teach you a completely
different timing and Direction mode
namely split time opposites here's how
that would work find yourself a wall to
stand in front of and you're going to
reach both hands out to the side now
from here you're going to reach one hand
up and one hand down and then bring them
back together at the other side of the
wall now the hand that went down before
is going to go up
and the hand that went up before is
going to go down and you bring them back
together to the side so as you touch the
wall you want to bring your hands around
in circles going in opposite directions
and meeting up at either side of your
body once you get to feel comfortable
with that you can try doing it without
the wall that is try just doing that wax
on wax off pattern with both of your
hands in midair really important you
want to make sure that your right hand
is going around clockwise relative to
you and your left hand is going around
counterclockwise relative to you like so
okay so once that motion feels
comfortable you're going to try doing
the same thing with the POI in your
hands and once again treating the POI
like they are extensions of your arms
and what you're going to find is that
you're actually doing that one two one
two Rhythm just the POI happen to be
spinning in the same plane the one
adjustment we have yet to make is to
switch the POI around to spinning on the
sides of you rather than in front of you
so in order to do that what you want to
think is that the toy are going to turn
into wagon wheels that are spinning on
either side of you that is the axle of
those Wagon Wheels is basically going
straight out from either one of your
shoulders ideally you want to be able to
get yourself to the point where you can
comfortably do 10 beats reverse in this
split timing here thinking that one POI
is going up while the other is going
down again I kind of think of this as
like doing a drum beat like a roll on a
snare or something like that but you may
find that there's an entirely different
picture that works in your mind and that
works just as well
step 3 learn the reverse two beat weave
so just like with the forwards three
beat weave sometimes performing a
reverse three beat weave is helped by
first learning how to do a simple two
beat weave what's the difference here
well when we do a two beat weave we're
doing it in such a way that the same
hand is always going underneath and when
we switch up to the three beat weave you
will be able to feel the difference
trust me now crucially one thing that I
see a lot of people doing when they try
to do a reverse two beat is that their
hands start moving the POI at the same
time across their bodies which usually
means that the POI fall into working in
together Time same direction and
remember we want to keep them in Split
Time same direction so how exactly do we
get our hands to move in sync that way
all right so here's how we get there
you're going to go ahead and let out one
POI all the way and you're going to
start spinning it reverse on its own
side of the body in this case I'm doing
it with my right hand and I'm going to
take my left hand and I'm going to reach
over and touch my right wrist now once
that happens I'm going to switch my
right hand over to being on my left side
again the POI is going to be spinning
reverse I'm going to use a Tic Tac to
get there now I'm going to touch my left
hand to my right wrist and bring my
right hand back to the right so this is
a sequence it's a one two one two kind
of thing I touch left hand or right
wrist right hand moves over left hand or
right wrist Right Moves over I touch
switch touch switch touch switch touch
switch cool so now we want to take that
same timing and apply it when we have
both POI in motion so think that the
left hand is going to reach over towards
the right and that is what starts the
right moving over to the left like so I
tap right wrist and take it back right
wrist and take it back right wrist and
take it back right wrist and take it
back
[Music]
and of course we want to learn this on
both sides so go ahead and wrap up both
the POI and then let out the one on your
left side start it spinning reverse over
here on your left hand side and let the
right hand reach over and touch your
left wrist your left hand is then going
to switch over to your right side and
your right hand is going to touch your
left wrist again
the left hand goes back to the left side
touch to the Right Touch to the left
touch to the Right Touch to the left you
want to get a one two one two feeling as
you touch and switch so once you've got
two beat weaves down on both sides you
want to practice being able to do 10
reps of each one that is be able to have
your right hand go under for 10 reps in
a row and you also want to be able to do
10 reps with your left hand going under
10 times in a row when you can do both
you're ready for the next step
step four alternate between weaves
alright so now that you've got your two
beat weaves done on both sides you're
going to have to learn how to switch
back and forth between them so that you
can switch which hand is leading at any
given point here's how we go ahead and
do that now go ahead and start spinning
your POI reverse split Time same
direction on either side of your body
and what I want you to do is start off
by taking your right hand under
so I want you to count off
one two three beats with your right take
it under and back and now with the left
hand count off three two one beats take
it under and Back Again three two one
right hand under three two one left hand
under going back and forth between the
two when it gets to feel comfortable
doing three of these beats in between
switching up go down to only doing two
beats that is think one two switch
around and one two switch around one two
switch round one two switch around the
final form of this POI Pokemon of course
is that we're gonna get down to only
doing one beat in between switching up
which hand is going under so think one
right under one left under one right
under one left under
all right
[Music]
awesome so if you're comfortable
switching back and forth between which
hand is going under that means that
there's one more exercise to do and we
should be able to put the entire thing
together into a reverse three beat weave
step 5 learn the three beat pattern
all right so we know how to do our two
beat weaves but to transform those into
a three beat weave we need to well add
another beat here's how we do that you
need to basically practice doing two
beats on the non-native side so if I'm
using my right hand I want to count off
doing one and then one two beats on my
left one one two beats on my left one on
the right one two on the left one on the
right one two on the left so how does
that work with the other hand I am so
glad you asked so there's a little drill
that I can teach you to figure out what
the pattern is going to be with the
other hand and it's actually going to
start by touching your hand to your
chest and I want you to go ahead and
just perform Tic Tacs going back and
forth with one hand as you're doing this
I want you to take that hand that's
touching your chest and reach out
directly above the other hand
get used to feeling it just kind of
hanging out there in space and with any
luck it's going to be as likely to hit
the POI as the hand holding it next
return your hand to your chest and as
that hand employer Going tick-tacking
Back and Forth Reach Out Below that hand
you want to feel just as comfortable
having that hand hanging out in space
above the hand as it is hanging out
below the hand cool now the pattern you
need to remember is this under over back
under over back now here's what that's
going to look like as you spin the POI
you're going to switch over to having
the POI and the Hand underneath the hand
that's just hanging out here and as it
completes a single beat you're going to
let the movement of the POI as it swings
away from you take it around above the
other hand
so you're going to think under over back
under over back under over back under
over back
and as with all things we want to learn
this on both sides so make sure that
both your right hand and your left hand
are trained to do under over back under
over back like so
step six putting it all together
all right so here's how we put all these
pieces together go ahead and start with
your POI spinning on either side of your
body in Split Time same direction and
what I want you to do is I want you to
focus on one hand to begin with let's
say the right hand and you're going to
have the right hand go under over and
back again it's going to go under over
and back this is almost certainly going
to feel really weird to start off with
and you want to make sure that both the
under and the over are over here on your
left hand side but in the end you should
wind up having these moments where the
hands are twisting around each other for
just a moment now you want to switch
focus and try and do the same thing with
your left hand thinking it's going to go
under over and back again we do under
over and back now the good news is is
that if you can do this with both the
right hand and the left hand you're
actually already doing the reverse three
beat weave it's just a question of being
able to do it continuously the last step
in this process that I find is generally
to think that I'm just switching off
which hand is going under so I think
right under left under right under left
under and I want to do this in such a
way that I'm constantly twisting my
hands and leading them back and forth
across my body
foreign
[Music]
so that's it dear friends the reverse
three beat weave hopefully that made the
Pieces come together for you and if not
please leave me a comment and let me
know where you got stuck and maybe I can
help you out did you get anything out of
this video please leave me a comment
like share and subscribe to help other
people find this video and of course to
help my channel grow
[Music]
foreign
would not be possible without the kind
support of all of these lovely people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon they and the people
listed down in the description helped to
make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible thank you one and
all for your very generous support
if you out there watching are not
currently supporters but you'd like to
become supporters you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can find a whole host of awesome rewards
but even better than that you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out more of my beginner POI lessons and
tutorials I will go ahead and include a
link to a playlist of those down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you are watching this video on
YouTube thank you so much for watching
make sure you get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace